what about your parents what are they
thinking now
that this your mom helps you sort of
find the Publishers who find this who
you get an audition and you meet Chris
Columbus and you get the part you have
one line that you improvise on or they
gave you on set and they're like oh okay
that's cute she's part of this big thing
but you know when did they go oh my gosh
this is you are part of that you really
are part of this yeah I think it was
also sometimes even when we were filming
it hard to Fathom the scale as it was
like growing into this phenomenon and I
think often it was really weirdly the
premieres that made you kind of just
just the noise of the fans in Leicester
Square and hearing like oh whoa it it's
a huge this is a massive deal and you
know every year we I went to the
premieres of my family and it always
felt like they were the moments where we
kind of looked at each other like what
is this what what are we in like this is
wild
um so it was always fun to to fill feel
those moments because often it was such
a kind of close-knit community on the
set sometimes it didn't even just became
really normal you know yes life does
whatever you your normal is
um so those were kind of cool
um but I don't know I mean I'm sure they
were
as any parent is like worried as well as
excited just to make sure that I feel
safe yeah safe protected you know happy
still doing it you know I think you from
9 to 19 years old as I was in the series
like that's a massive
period of your life where like a lot is
going on I mean you're really growing up
yeah and you still have a lot to do I
mean 19 is still young you know so but
those are like that's 10 years of your
life that's half of your first 19 years
you're on set you're experiencing this
world Fame how did you take it like when
did people recognize you instantly
yeah I mean obviously as the character
grew it was like an inevitable
um uh thing that would grow into being
more recognizable I mean I feel on the
scale of
some of the other actors I feel
you know I had a relatively like I could
still have a normal life you know I took
the tube to school and I went you know I
lived in the half London and I was kind
of out and about and doing my thing you
know there were some days where you did
suddenly be like oh my God I want to you
know run away and hide in a box or
something and then other days it was
like kind of forgot that I was played
this big character
um so ebden flowed and I think as you're
going through those kind of awkward
teenage years sometimes it's quite
difficult because you often just want to
kind of be swallowed up with the crowd
as you sometimes do as a teenager yeah
in those awkward days or moments when
you don't feel great so that was
sometimes challenging just when you're
kind of figuring out who you are anyway
and that people have this idea of who
you are right it's like a yeah I guess
I'm that person but I'm also like all
these other people that I'm figuring out
yeah hey there folks it's Michael
Rosenbaum and boy have I got a huge
announcement for you this has been a
long time coming and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're going to
make it a lot of fun we're planning a q
a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there it just seems
like I was so immature I'm still
immature but I I feel like if I had that
sort of Fame
I don't know I might be like you know
kind of acting a certain way maybe in
front of my parents like um you're
talking to a star hello Jeweler listen I
mean were you at all did you ever did
your mom ever have to put you in place
you're like all right listen Miss
actress do you remember being a young
actress you know actor and then like
listen all right you're you're not in
this house I mean do you remember any of
that
however I hope was never like that it
was never like put in my place from my
behavior I think it was more just
sometimes realizing the opportunity and
privilege I had through that role and
what I was able to do I think my parents
like kept me level-headed in that way
but I honestly think
all of us because we were we had each
other and we were the same age and we
were kind of experiencing this thing at
the same time I think it was much easier
than what I could maybe imagine being
like a single child actor on a
predominantly you know adult set because
you are you kind of don't know exactly
where you where are you still a child or
are you now just entirely a professional
so
I kind of loved the fact that we were
all a similar age and
off camera we were doing our classes
together and studying and just doing
normal kid things and teenage things so
yeah that kind of was super helpful it
felt less isolating in that way which is
I think when you start to think you're
above others when you begin to be a bit
isolated